à tous cyril tu dis toujours que la
valeur la plus importante c'est
l'honnêteté mais est ce que tu penses
que tous les chroniqueurs autour de la
table sont honnêtes avec toi cyril tu
dis toujours que la valeur la plus
importante à tes yeux c'est l'honnêteté
penses tu que les gens autour de la
table sont toujours honnête avec toi et
c'est vrai que merci pour cette question
merci ma roue qui a 20 ans et je n'ai
mao je te le dis j'espère que les gens
sont sincères avec moi est ce que vous
pensez y si m'étais bien votre main on
n'a pas sûr en adaptant la regarde pas
les batailles et ils sont arrivés très
bien notre main sur le détecteur de
mensonges et france est-ce que ici tout
le monde a toujours été sincère avec moi
et ne m'a jamais menti il avait ben oui
tu rates dit tout le monde c'est mon âge
peut-être mais ça va ça ça passe machine
à laver roy vrais mensonges un gros
mensonge en gros noms bon alors non moi
j'ai jamais menti en tout cas je
mentirais jamais non jamais non non non
moi j'avais on nous dit on et voilà mais
d'autres ont peut-être fait bouder bien
sûr j'étais là mais jamais bouder
servirait alors j'ai envie de vous dire
pour moi l'honnêteté c'est primordial
bahreïn est une famille sur celle ci on
commence à se mentir entre nous c'est l'
escalade de l'horreur carrément l
escalade de la violence au hockey ou qui
a alors voilà celle là je fais appel à
quoi est-ce que des gens des régions qui
ont triché pour qu'ils trichent et
autour de la table n'est pas un
chroniqueur est une invitée et auquel
n'importe laquelle oui quelqu'un qui
représente la france qui répond non mais
c'est pas qui représente la famille se
regarder et juste après je vais vous
parler regarde
[Musique]
valérie smadja
on va jouer maintenant avec clémence
quelle cité française est surnommée la
ville rose quel est le prénom d'antoine
griezmann enfin le dernier livre des
frères bogdanov a pour titre le visage
de dieu où nous ne mentons jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon c'est vrai moi c'est du non non vous
si l'euro mais je te je comprends les
téléspectateurs manque de respect mais
pas les tricheurs
la vie c'est un tennis je donne tu
donnes c'est la générosité sa première
télé images concernant mathieu mathieu
je vous le dis bien sûr vous mathieu par
exemple est ce que vous auriez pu
tricher comme elles n'ont jamais fait
jamais triché c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'à mon avis avec quinze ans que j'ai
en télé et au quotidien as
voilà est ce que d'ailleurs à dieu ça
vous dirait de revoir un très beau
moment de télévision
j'en ai plusieurs du gouffre j'ai eu la
star ac j'ai eu tellement vrai je vous
rappelle des jeux des bois bat alors
lequel vous avez gagné une co animation
avec moi ben oui des requêtes ont fait
ça il faut qu'on apprenne à 1,5 en votre
victoire regarder lens issam touche
faisons le jeu des boîtes et matthieu
delormeau brève de quoi animer
reprennent avec moi en 2020 sur ses
beats vous l'avez y être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la sexuelle et qui ensuite dans les
alpes les gens m'ont reparler de ce
moment quand c'est sincère ce moment de
télé ce qu'on a personnage et je sais
c'est très beau et à noël mathieu vous
aviez choisi la boîte 9 mai dans la
boîte 9 il y avait le prime time
cette boîte si vous vous en souvenez
mathieu vous la vouliez absolument
feeling alors on va revoir
regardez mercredi dernier je prends la
6è la raison
alors je sais laquelle je veux un voulé
laquelle vous c'est une révélation
divine c'est quoi 9
j'aimerais juste récupérer mon bien la
neuve depuis le début ça fait bizarre
mais c'est à droite
plus personne ne change rien du tout
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné je garde la 9 71
soit pas pu c'est la 6 e à la 5 et 9 mai
elle comprend un fusain mathieu tu le
prime où le bouche à bouche
regardes-tu la boîte numéro 9 oui le
prime time dans la 9,6 de passe aussi je
peux déjà prévenir le real cam à fond
sur moi les autres étoiles alors mathieu
est la question que je me pose c'est
est-ce que vous avez des dons de
mentalist vous savez ce que vous avez de
la chance ou peut-être est-ce autre
chose autre chose
expliquez-nous pourquoi cet acharnement
à vouloir la boîte numéro 9 à moi aussi
je veux bien savoir ça vous avez cyril
en 1988
ayrton senna avait prévu qu'il sache un
peu du monde
il l'a été et si vous voulez tout savoir
sur cyril je rappelle que ce jeu c'est
terminé puisque vous montrer des images
qui vous arrange et non pas de ceux qui
ne les arrange pas je vous rappelle que
ce jeu s'est terminée par un un chiffon
me comptage on donnait sa main comme ça
vous comptiez et à la fin tatatata ça
sera toi qui choisira ta boîte et j'ai
choisi la neuf donc j'avais une chance
sur trois de perdre vous voulez
absolument l'a9 attendait à ça ça vous
en souvenez de sa de ce petit schumi
et c'est vrai que je voulais absolument
l'a9 je voulais votre main pardon je
voulais l'a9 parce que j'ai eu
effectivement et je les dis je ne mens
jamais une révélation divine
cette boîte m'est tombé dessus tel un
message de dieu il faut les experts il
parle d'une voix m'a dit je n'ai pas
d'oreillette rang l'a9 tourne à venir
est dedans je me souviens de sa
notamment parce que c'était dit en
anglais longtemps encore fait l'actu et
agenda
mathieu est photo prise le 19 décembre
le jeu des boîtes il y avait quelques
tweets quelque peu suspicieux qu'on va
revoir
il ya céline il disait encore de la
triche car il était sûr que derrière la
noce il y avait le prime benoît c'est
facile pour lui comme d'habitude il a
triché comme une fois déjà
mouloud il a triché encore elle se
trouve delphine c'est cyril hanouna ce
n'est pas possible matthieu delormeau a
triché à chaque fois qu'il ya des boîtes
ils gagnent toujours il ya de la triche
là dessous il n'avait jamais gagné
cécilia qui dit moi je demande enquête
riche qui est d'accord après avoir revu
les images
j'ai peut-être d'autres preuves mais
j'aimerais d'abord que chaque
chroniqueur nous donne son sentiment au
pire une dernière chose à dire pour cela
et si vous avez chacun d'eux papier
devant vous un papier tricheur et un
papier wind à elle son visage sera dans
un instant pour l'instant on va écouter
mathieu mathieu est ce que oui ou non
vous avez triché lors du jeu des boîtes
votre main
j'espère 482
[Applaudissements]
vous devez la vérité
que s'est il passé dans cette chambre
200 dos du sofitel
je vous le dire la vérité j'ai entendu
effectivement une révélation une voix
divine
en tout cas que j'ai cru divine
[Applaudissements]
maintenant j'ai pas mal je me suis mais
qui je me suis promené bages et j'ai été
prendre un peu l'air j'étais très aimée
vous souvenez de mon émotion à ce moment
là j'ai dû sortir du plateau pour pour
cacher mon émotion et reprendre mon
souffle taquine mch group
je suis sortie du plateau et j'ai eu
cette révélation divine j'ai entendu
prend la 9ème bien sûr mais est ce que
cette voie était dans ma tête
est-ce que je devrais dire mais j'ai
entendu cette voix prend la nef est pour
moi le venait de ma tête
t'entends pas prend la porte là
[Rires]
mathieu je vous le dis moi je crois que
ce que je vois à tanguer alors j'ai
demandé à tous qui or de retrouver
toutes les images de cette soirée encore
elle notamment les images pendant les
pubs celles que personne ne voit à
l'écran j'ai également de demander de ré
écouter les sons de tous les micros des
chroniqueurs un dossier urgent et 7,9
car lorsque je ne vois pas jean-claude
en temps j'entends regardez bien et
faites vous votre avis chez vous et vous
aussi
autour de la table regarde
dis moi tu es time j'avais du mal
pourquoi
encore là bien de gravité
les gars
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu duquesne à avoir le temps de
faire de te faire votre plaidoirie mais
juste avant
sachez chers chroniqueur que vous avez
de papier dont tricheurs ou winner pour
savoir si si vous voulez que matthieu
delormeau faire de son prime vous mettez
tricheurs je voulais que matthieu
delormeau garde son prime vous mettez
winner je vous le dis ça ne sert à rien
de penser que le problème sera
redistribué si matthieu delormeau le
père ce prime ira directement google
mais attendez moi quelque chose si
vraiment une majorité de tricheurs
autour de la table non je vais pas le
problème c'est moi qui déciderai
derrière a donc je peux avoir que des
tricheurs je peux faire et en même temps
c'est comme d'habitude c'est la
dictature totale d'accord c'est
également un homme de lui ce monsieur
est également le public qui va décider
mais sa soeur ou winner commencé à voter
c'est parti je vais passer avec ma
petite urne
mettez moi juste tee shirt sur wii dans
le monde par d'ingénieux de nouveautés
mais ça ne sert à rien que le désirez
après si si ça sert vous allez voir
pourquoi car chacun va se faire un avis
voilà pas assez expliqué nous personne
montre si bien sûr mais jean-michel oui
jean michel vous allez vous expliquer
dans un instant qui est dit également
merci merci merci
merci et vous dire je sais ce que tu
fais pas je disais dit matthieu
delormeau a tué est-ce que vous avez
triché ou pas vous allez nous le dire
dans un instant mais juste avant je vais
faire et le dépouillement tricheurs
cebenna salle est jalouse tricheurs
[Rires]
winner a jamais vu leur qui sait pas ce
que c'est isabelle morini-bosc mon bébé
la crise solo sur la lafa oui c'est vrai
mais n'a marqué qu'un patch lama castadi
donc tricheurs sur believe et novelli
tricheurs sur isabelle morini bosc
ouais je pense qu'il n'a pas triché ne
sera pas dedans quand même laissé sur ce
qu'on a vu la preuve c'est jean-michel
salut mes meilleures amies mais mal de
ce fait je le connais très bien
tricheur henry chan a mis tricheurs
benjamin castaldi fraîcheur d'élite sûr
poursuit-il c'est moi qui est qui et qui
j'ajoute énorme je suis a dit donc faire
une raymond ya pas de doute ces [ __ ]
genton winner les antilles parce que je
pense qu'il n'a pas triché je pense que
c'est un excellent animateur il mérite
sa chance sur sa vitrine n'a jamais
vraiment eu sa chance mais d'abord est
ce que j'aime bien c'est parce qu'ils
méritaient ce que la triche et oui il a
pas triché je pense qu'il a pas triché
valérie bénaïm triche à moi aussi j'aime
bien mais c'est un tricheur tauscher a
triché pour enfin géraldine maillet
wheeler ouais il a ça dans le sang la
triche pourquoi je pense qu'elle est
petite piste mais que c'est pas assez
flagrant et dont je dois je ne vais pas
tout montrer c'était sur mathieu je vais
vous dire on va voir le résultat
oui je réponds juste à des internautes
ce qu'on a entendu une phrase dans une
paix juste avant
mathieu est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce que vous pensez de tout ça non mais
reste yasmine le permet vous permettra
même avis que je joue lorsque vous
entendez lorsque tout le public entend
la france et peut-être les gens
l'étranger entendent c'est la bonne
c'est pas la bonne je parle d'une
bouteille d'orangeade que j'étais en
train d'échanger avec un collaborateur à
l'extérieur du truc
oui c'est la bonne passe ta moi elle est
bonne c'était la bouteille dans les pas
de la boîte vous avez que c'est la boîte
quand je dis je vais la produire
résident également
je parle de cette orangeade que j'adore
sucré et que je souhaiterais produire
car c'est une orangeade qu'on devrait
plus diffuser genre
ce pas ce soir est exceptionnel les yeux
dans les yeux cyril j'ai entendu je le
redis j'ai une j'ai entendu une voix
d'où venait-elle je ne sais pas elle
sauf que je ne suis je suive à la
catholique n'appréciait pas toutes les
preuves de tout donc non je n'ai pas
triché
je m'assieds j'ai la main dessus et je
crois que ma main dit effectivement
mathieu tu vois quoi mathieu je vais
vous dire quelque chose à te faire chier
je vous dire quelqu'un a tous je veux
dire que c'est ça ma excuse pour manger
le prime non non ça va être ça rodolphe
mathieu mathieu jeu proposé un deal un
dédit peut-être nenni peut-être que j'ai
la preuve en image que tu as triché et
peut-être que cette preuve je ne la
mettrait pas si tu me dis droit dans les
yeux j'ai triché mais alors à temps si
tu m'as voutaz triche il garde le prime
et il garde le price a bien oui c'est
comme ça c'est bon je ne montrerai pas
l'épreuve pas où et n'importe quoi à ce
que chez geos calais veut dire oui bah
oui mais si mais si
non si tu n'avoues pas c'est très simple
ou peut-être je te blust et je n'ai pas
de preuve ou peut-être j'ai vraiment des
preuves et là tu perdras le prime si je
n'ai pas de preuve tu garderas le prime
vous avez une intuition ou malgré tout
une petite
calmez vous y adhère ou pas je pense que
s'il avoue ça vous de décider ce qui va
faire le premier exactement je déciderai
si vous avouer je veux dire quelque
chose
mifare cyril berne bien fort oui
regardez la france n'avait absolument
aucune preuve
c'est du bluff c'est de la justice
japonaise à la carlos ghosn 20 19 % des
gens et bien prévenus condamnés évadés
l'avion condamné on est noir donc je
peux vous dire
mais merde donc j'ai pas vous dire
qu'effectivement vous n'avez pas cette
preuve vous bluffer donc j'ai mon prime
time tu me files et arrête de me faire
chier
[Applaudissements]
les chéris si vous nous rejoignez sachez
qu'il ya de grosses suspicion de triche
concernant mathieu delormeau et son
prime time il avait égalé reprenne
talent c'était le 19 décembre avant
qu'on parte en vacances et matthieu
delormeau avait dit qu'il n'avait pas
triché voulait absolument la boîte
numéro 9 matthieu delormeau
ma question et va être simple joli et ça
va compter bien entendu pour ma décision
finale d'abord je vais voir le sondage
des twittos c'est ce qu'ils en pensent
winner ou tricheur et proposer quelque
chose
nombre de minutes déjà c'est si c'est
moi qui propose moi je m'embrouille ça
fait assez de mal comme ça commence à
s'alléger de piéger vous êtes vous êtes
en plus ses vues menace voilà là on a on
à le changer ici merci on va la voir
dans deux heures pendant mes os
pensez vous que mathieu d'anjou mérite
de commissaires à la question qui va la
question mais sur la question
mary grill au fond du laitier content de
ce résultat je n'ai pas à répondre à
cela
d'accord parce que puis je vous dire
pourquoi j'ai rallié parce que
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'animateur je
viens voir c'est l'homme l'homme
et ses qualités l'animateur j'ai déjà
assez loué ses qualités maintes et
maintes faut maintenant quand je
présente une émission j'ai envie d'avoir
un homme droit avec bien un homme bien
ou un homme honnête sans côté de moi
enfin maison les ans et non pas les op
non matthieu delormeau la boîte numéro 9
est ce que vous l'avez choisie par pur
hasard ou est-ce que matthieu delormeau
vous avez triché
c'est pas parce que vous allez dire la
vérité que le prince ne se sera pas et
c'est pas parce que vous allez mentir
que le prince s'offre à former compris
mais a perdu c'est bien je peux répondre
oui cyril je vous ai versé sur de books
easy péremptoire insu comminatoire et
bien cyril je veux dire quelque chose
non seulement j'ai pas tricher mais
écoutez moi bien si effectivement vous
n'avez pas la preuve car vous ne l'avez
pas je vois dans les yeux que vous
mentez
si vous n'avez pas la preuve puisque
vous m'avez mise en cause devant la
france entière
j'ai deux prime et si vous avez la
preuve que j'ai triché
j'annule celui là et je gêne il celui là
et on réfléchira tous ensemble à une
sanction mais j'ai encore ce bateau qui
décide mon petit bonhomme
si tu n'as pas la preuve ce que tu m'as
mis en cause j'ai deux corps elle veut
devenir producteur en octobre sont
assurés dacquois importe qui n'a pas la
preuve avouer n'importe quoi matthieu
delormeau
je vous le dis j'ai la preuve du mans
j'ai subi à la paf ya des caméras
partout il ya de l'environnement sur ce
que j'ai dit
alors moi j'ai la preuve son auriez dû
avouer voilà je voulais c'est leur
dernière chance je vais les laisser 10
secondes pourquoi ta décision laissez-le
parce que j'aime bien je laisse une
dernière chance de lormont sachez que
j'ai des caméras partout chez les micros
partout si je montre la preuve je vous
le dis il n'y aura plus jamais de prime
et non non non vous auriez monte bah
c'est peu dire second dix états comme je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sais btp mathieu franchement pour la
vérité ne dit pas la vérité à votre
collègue dit la vérité
aquatre alma votre ami alors je me la
vraie vérité
non ça suivre en toute honnêteté ça
suffit mais franchement c'est pas des
vocations
j'ai posé une seule question gras dans
les yeux oui avez-vous te le 3 mai dit
oui ou non rampe
ça semble qu'à cannes se sentir je vous
montrerai les propre nom après l'intro
de vivre de tpb gars france ou sinon
matthieu delormeau si vous avez des ses
dernières chances malheureusement oui
les n'zima vrai montré les images gens
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout n'est pas trop
galère vous savez que vous avez triché
n'en auriez dû me dire la vérité ou si
magique ayant dû révéler la vérité c'est
toujours payant si ça te le dire la
vérité à papa pour nous faut dire la
vérité soit maintenant n'allez pas faire
le prime annoncée non benjamin girbal
cent restant là sans la preuve même
parce que j'aime ce que je vais vous
montrer la preuve le monde de la télé et
ils crurent
la fin et deux claques je sais pas tu
avais peur qu est-ce qui va tourner amis
oui parce que tu sais que tu aimes bien
je vais faire ce problème avec toi ça
mais non ça m'énerve parce que je pense
qu'on aurait fait un magnifique travail
tous les deux passer ses week c'est non
je pense que tu entends trenet c'est de
faire que je n'ai pas parce que pas du
tout n'a été menacée par l'autre et la
nature mais répondait les deux heures du
matin il a vérité la vérité dit la
vérité et tu verras si tu me dis la
vérité tu feras ce prime avec moi alors
on va rajouter une case non tu feras
suprématie tari la vérité j'ai peut-être
30 j'ai peut-être non oui non il n'y a
pas de la vie c'est pas blanc ou noir
syrie merde c'est j'ai triché ma binaire
c'est pas 0 1 puis par un ordi j'ai
triché osé pas triché j'ai j'ai triché
j'y allais à vous les gars des vues
faute avouée
j'ai peut-être ne pas été dans
l'honnêteté la plus totale heures mais
sait pas alors c'est dénoncé lundi les
régimes et où les faits ont été avec moi
j'écris j'ai eu de la chance est riche
et riche mais chez cgg moitié c'est à
moi à tomber
dis-moi oui la triche notamment surpris
les chiens c'est pas trés chez lui mais
chéri
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'attentât raté trois fois le pacte a
bien triché au dernier oui bon ben voilà
il avoué la vie oui on a avoué l'avouer
il a battu e rien vous et c'est ton ami
qui parle maintenant c'est aux
producteurs
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu ton producteur à deux choses est
bien mais que trois choses à l'égard des
jeunes mais déjà un mathieu même si tu
as mis du temps
bravo d'avoir avoué faute avouée 100%
par données ont également créé kastali
deep et avouée à moitié pardonnée faire
avouer nature avoué la deuxième chose
que j'aime bien chez qu'il n'avait
aucune preuve développer je n'avais
aucune preuve jeudi je tenais bon poker
celui à la troisième chose que j'aime
bien c'est que ce prime
on va le faire
[Applaudissements]